it's not the first call to arms by an
ethiopian leader but this time it's
against an enemy within
prime minister abi ahmed used the first
anniversary of the conflict in tigrai to
call on its citizens to fight and defeat
the tiguan rebels
until ethiopia is free and peaceful this
is the time every citizen has to say i'm
an ethiopian soldier to condemn this
mischievous plan while standing next to
the ethiopian national defense forces to
humiliate the enemy
late last year the ethiopian national
army with a strength in numbers and
significant air power pushed the tigran
rebels into retreat
but since july the rebels have been
making new gains expanding the battle
from inside tigray into neighbouring
amhara and afar regions
they have now entered an unlikely
alliance with the oromo liberation army
a banned armed splinter group from
oromia region home to ethiopia's largest
ethnic group when the federal military
had to withdraw from tigray
in june after suffering significant
battlefield losses and that really does
seem to have depleted the federal
military um they've been on recruitment
campaigns since um including enlisting
these regional forces and militia
but ultimately that means sending quite
raw
new recruits into battle
and that seems to have contributed to
the
fairly consistent gains by the tigray
forces through eastern amhara the rebels
are threatening to move further south
towards addis ababa after capturing two
strategic towns on a major highway
linking the northern tigray region with
the capital
where the tigran leadership is highly
unpopular
soldiers are not fighting alone we
should know that for sure our forces
will never surrender despite all that
you might see on social media or on
satellite tv we don't need to heed the
advice of foreigners about how to deal
with this conflict this is our war
against those who attempt to enslave us
the u.s has been calling for immediate
negotiations without preconditions to
end the conflict it's allowing voluntary
departure of some of its staff and their
family members in the capital because of
escalating violence
washington has sent its special envoy
for the horn of africa to ethiopia and
there are also regional efforts to
de-escalate the ugandan president has
called a meeting of the east african
block to discuss the crisis
for now addis ababa remains on edge as
neither side shows any sign of backing
down
priyanka gupta al-jazeera
okay let's bring in independent
journalist samuel getachow in addis
ababa hello there samuel how are
ethiopians reacting to these latest
developments
ethiopians are really concerned the u.s
the biden administration envoy is in
town
saying that there has to be some kind of
negotiation
to end this conflict that began a year
ago it was echoed by the president of
uganda the president of kenya putting so
much pressure to the ethiopian
government as well as the tpnf to
somehow find a solution to a conflict
that started a year ago and has produced
millions of victims from all sides it's
not just in tegra it's also in amhara
and afar as reflected by the un report
that came out yesterday with the support
of the ethiopian human rights
the victims are just so overwhelming and
mounting by that
each day and what has really highlighted
been highlighted about this conflict is
the sexual violence that has been used
by all actors according to the report
so just how critical will this meeting
be which will be held by the east
african block later this month
that will be on november 16th uh the
ugandan president is seen as an elder uh
and a younger generation around
governments all over in the horn of
africa um and it's going to be one of
the options to bring this to a
conclusion because once again the u.n is
saying uh there's going to be some sort
of famine in ethiopia coming back to an
old era and there's also foreign
investment and the issue of foreigners
fleeing ethiopia putting
the image of the country in a very
compromising position
thank you very much for your insight
samuel gedichow let's bring in talad
masood for his analysis he's a retired
lieutenant general and a military
analyst who's been closely following
developments in ethiopia he joins us
from islamabad hello there tala thanks
for joining us
are government forces strong enough to
withhold the tplf as they advance
towards the capital
well i
don't think that will end the conflict
because it's very important that both
the sides should come
out with a political settlement it's a
thing
you know the civil war will continue as
long as force is used
uh to sort of quill uh in this present
civil war
i think you need a political solution
for that and you also need a sort of
justice which has been completely denied
in this case and there is so much of
brutality
and
you know there is no humanity left
anymore
in
this conflict and i think both the sides
but the government has to be more
responsible and they are really setting
such a bad standard
that
and the pres and the prime minister is
you know ahmad is very adamant in trying
not to be very conciliatory
he seems to sort of deny the opportunity
which is being afforded by his neighbors
to sort of come to some sort of a
political engagement
with the plf but he doesn't seem to
really agree to that so it's a situation
wherein i think the civil war will
continue until there is some either
change in the leadership or
there are some compulsive forces which
really prevent things
you know happening what they are but at
this point of time with this president
and with this sort of
policy and attitude it becomes extremely
difficult to find a way out of this
brutal civil war which has
really taken the lives of millions of
people and not only the lives but the
quality of lives and the future of that
country and all the people of the region
has been seriously impacted and affected
adversely
tala the u.n high commissioner for human
rights has called for calm is that
enough is the international community in
ethiopia's neighbours doing enough to
call for khan
well i think that effort is okay but uh
the fact is i couldn't agree more that
there has to be far greater effort
and far greater focus actually what
happens is that the major powers are
least interested in these areas and they
think that these humans are not
important and this is one of the saddest
commentary that you can
see
what's happening in the sense that and
there is not a realization at the global
level
even at the african level and that what
is happening
in this part of the world so i think and
it's a sad reflection of the overall
quality of leadership and i think the un
also has to be far more active
although i think
the u.n rights chief did
is taking a lot of interest but that is
not enough uh i think the united nations
security council the u.n
organizations the african countries i
think they all should really focus on
that and should america and also the
major powers china and russia also
should take some interest if they are
responsible major powers
so just how critical is this meeting to
be held by the east african block later
this month what needs to be what is to
happen in that meeting
yeah well i think
they might come out with some sort of a
conciliatory approach but whether will
that be accepted by the parties
concerned that is a big question
well we appreciate your insights talat
massoud a retired lieutenant general and
military analyst thank you for your time
thank you